everyone i am mateo kolina
and today we are going to talk about the
node.js http client
um what can be so interesting about it
well
what if i could tell you that
um you know you could just double the
throughput of your http client or
even better uh maybe you know
triple the triplet so you know we can do
that
and we'll see how a couple of things
about me before we start i am mateo
kolina you can follow me on twitter at
mathulina please
you know follow me back i'm also a
part of nier form uh technical directors
there
we are a professional services company
based in ireland so if you
are interested you know working for us
check us out we are hire globally and
remotely so hey
we are also i'm also a member of the
node.js technical steering committee
so i'm part of the of node
and i'm the co-creator of a few bits and
bobs on
npm i also write every week and i take
an
unused letter called nodeland so you
know check us out
um uh i maintain a lot
of open source including node so uh
as part of my activity of both as a
consultant
and as as a maintainer i tend to
strike and maintain a balance and
feedbacks my learning
from when i help companies to when i
maintain things in the ecosystem
as part of this activity i tend to write
and build new things when the
opportunity arises
so uh most applications
start as a monolith you know there's
nothing bad about talking about
monoliths most
apps start as a monolith they're great
and fastify the framework framework that
i've built
is great for building monoliths so um
you know it's uh it has almost 900
000 downloads per month and 15
collaborators
we are working on version 4 now and we
have a lot of ecosystem plugins so it's
pretty great
and it works really well it's also part
of the openjs
foundation so i have another talk about
it so i'm not going to spend so much
time about
about fastify
however once we are built our monolith
one of the hardest question is how do we
start scaling our teams how do we start
scaling
how do we start oh sorry how do we start
scaling our teams how do we start
improving our system well we'll see that
in a second
so um the what we want to do in those
cases
is that is we want to um
is we want to move to what's called a
micro service architecture
and where we have some sort of gateway
that
talks to several micro services as you
can see in
in our as you can see in your um
in the slide so however this is not
just that because in most complex
uh in the most complex
enterprises and projects the reality is
way way way more
uh gets very complicated very quickly
because you have several layers of
microservices that talk to each other
now the throughput and latency that each
one of those introduce
it it's critical for the system so
and it's one of the most bits that tend
to not
tend to be overlooked when opting for
microservice architecture so
and by the way fastify is one of the
architectures
fastify is great for building
microservices also lambdas by the way
but it's great for building
microservices so please use fastify when
building um as part of this talk we are
going to go through
and look at these links between the
microservices
and now we can use http to provide some
debug
a link between the microservices easily
debuggable but also very very performant
so let's uh
let's dig deep into into this topic okay
so um
it's um you know look at this
because it's if you want to make it fast
it's
you know uh that link can
add up pretty quickly because if you add
more more levels of latency you know if
that link becomes low
then all your system is low so
let's take about a little very simple
server this server is an http server
virtually node
that you know just respond with a given
timeout
easy and the client
the http client for this is uh
again it's very simple you call it
ship.get but you can also use
axios notepads request got whatever you
have
and you can call and then you can just
you know
pipe it pipe the answer back somewhere
somewhere
note that this call this system by
default
allocates a new tcp socket for every ccp
for every http request so one new socket
for every request and we get
we dispose it this is not efficient
creating a socket we'll see it's
this is not efficient because creating a
socket involves
several round trips so on the on our
uh on the on the server so essentially
when you establish a new socket
you need to do a sin you need to send a
synth type packet which then needs to be
replied by the server
now this is a back and forth and you are
actually losing
uh uh milliseconds here so if you are
on a very fast network like a server
this is actually not a big problem
but um you know you still have to
allocate you know file descriptors in
your open system system and so on so
forth so there's a limited amount of
these things that you can use
note that you get a little bit of of
latency as well
and part of the problem is also due to
the so-called tcp congestion window as
shown in this diagram by the way these
diagrams are from a book called
high performance browser networking
which i would highly recommend
you to uh to go and read
so this book it's so this is this
this congestion windows what you have is
you you can see that if i'm sending a
big packet
on a freshly created socket uh say sorry
if i'm sending a big file on on a
freshly created socket you know i need
to do a lot of round trips
because every once in a while i need to
send a knack to the server
and this is very important for http for
tcp because it ensures that all the
packets arrives in order
however you know the congestion windows
grows
over time and at some point it's
it's with using algorithms and so on it
stabilizes i don't want to enter all of
this stuff it's very important but you
know
outside of this talk what is important
is that
if i have if my socket has been open for
a while
the congestion windows is higher and
because it's higher
we can all we can send a lot of data
before sending a knack
now in the example on the right you can
see that if a big
if we have a biggest congestion window
we can always we can send
all our data in without receiving a
knack from the
from the sender this the in this way we
are actually reducing a lot
uh reducing the latency quite a lot
so in order to ensure the maximum
bandwidth and the minimum latency
we must reuse existing connections right
is that you know it's it's
this is a fair assessment um
so what it means what we we were doing
before creating a new connection every
time is not efficient
so in in node core we offer a construct
to do this which is creating an http
agent
http agents can keep the connection
alive so it avoids the handshake
and maximize the connection window it
uses the keeper
http 1.1 keep alive it's a key feature
of http 1.1
this is actually critical for tls
connections
because on top of the tcpn shake you
will also have the tls and jake
so if you don't have an agent and you're
calling with https
services you you're setting yourself up
for trouble
know that this is not the default so you
need to either to conf
you need to configure it manually for
your http client or to set
it or configure as a default in node so
it's very important that you do
because the difference can be staggering
now
let's turn the idea into reality
one of the the service scenario that i'm
going to test
it involves doing a a 500
request to one server and it's
uh which in turn does you know
another five
five requests to other microservices so
essentially
uh it's uh um you know it's a lot of
it's a lot of requests okay um
the server takes 10 milliseconds to
process the request and the client has a
limit of
50 sockets so all of these is fictional
so don't worry too much about it
do your measurements but the difference
is staggering so if you don't do
keep alive you will be in very very very
huge trouble
use http agent with keep alive
full stop the difference can be enormous
um so the key the secondary question
then after you've seen how we can
improve
the uh our client uh
you know it's
we can use an agent then right but can
we still can we improve things
further well we can actually we can
how well you know we need to go back
into this pack and look what's there
so is there something in http that can
allow us to actually
you know
work at a higher speed well there is
so one of the important bits is this
thing called hdp
1.1 pipelining
http 1.1 pipelining is
allows to send more than one request at
the same time
using the more than one inquest at the
same time
it's great so um
[Music]
minus one thing you know all the
responses with http 1.1
needs to be received in order so it's
suffer for
the so-called head-of-line blocking so
if the first request takes a lot of time
everything will have to wait however
this
it's it's a good technique it's
important to know that this is possible
because we can actually use it on our
server to server
note that out of line we need to talk a
little bit about head of line blocking
though
because if if you're doing this and you
start losing packets
or you know having a single slow request
you can actually block all the incoming
requests
uh for a while so be careful on how much
you are pipelining
the other important part that we need to
uh
to talk uh before you know making uh
a recommendation and you know discussing
how and why
we can actually improve the speed is the
event loop
um the in the event loop with node.js
event loop
we have um an event that uh you know
when
we actually we have a we have a
so-called event so it's called even loop
you know um events are
are not javascript though so we have you
have i o events iu events are can be
produced by the kernel or can be
produced by threadpool
and those events get put into a queue
once once an event is there node.js
can fetch that event and process it with
javascript
that's what it does that's all all of it
does and
with javascript you can schedule more
events to
happen in the future and then those will
be cued or maybe we can just say oh and
i finished processing this event uh
please uh send me the next one
that's what it does how does this
relating to pipelining we'll get there
in a second
but one of the important bit is to tell
to note how can we make things
fast in in
in node so in order to make things fast
you need to understand when the event
loop is blocked
so if you're doing massive io like in
this case
you need to you want to
[Music]
maximize the
you want to maximize the time that
node.js is doing io
this means minimizing the time david
loop is
blocked right well the event loop is
blocked when we are executing javascript
so in order to make things fast we need
to reduce the amount of time we spend in
javascript
down to zero if possible
and it's uh this is the key technique
that we have used
in in we can use to improve things okay
so um because
because we can
because we can schedule things you know
with http pipelining
um one of the that technique
combined with the event loop logic can
make sure
that when we are processing things
we are you know processing a lot of
events a lot of things from the server
or for the client and so on and so forth
so it's important uh note that
it's it's also important to note
that
with http pipelining you are going to
have
a lot of econ results you're risking
economy that so
if the other side is truncating your
connection before
uh you sent any data so
recently we have changed the keep alive
the keep alive agent to a logic of lifo
so last in first out
this means that this reduces the amount
of
these tend to use the most fresh sockets
so
it reduces the risk of them timing out
still the risk is still there though so
you need to configure your keep a live
timeout well um
so considering all of the knowledge that
we have went through so far
uh i am going to uh to show
you the one of the best thing that i
that i've wrote in in a while which is
this new library called
how it's owned why well it's an italian
word that means 11.
why 11 well one if you
consider the number one one then we have
hdp 1.1
so you see um
which is perfectly great uh note that
this is totally
a stranger things reference so if you
don't you know if you if you're
wondering if it's a
why it's called it's also it's totally
because stranger things because
when i was starting working on this
library
i ended up writing a
strangest thing was just came out so in
fact i've been developing this library
for
quite a long time um so
how does undigi work well when this is a
new
uh library for uh for node and
uh it keep alive by default so you don't
need to configure a keep a live agent
uh it also adds
a lifo uh it also has a lethal ali for
scheduler
so by default again it does not do any
pipelining by default
but it can be configured to do so and it
can create a limited connection
or by the way you can also follow
redirects note that this is really fresh
um it's a fresh syntax it use promises
you can also use callbacks if you want
but
maybe not and basically you can just you
know just
use the things that you like the most
it's very simple to use
note that you can only ch is similar to
node node as a concept of
agent and you can configure a global
agent if you want to do so
you can configure for example the
pipelining factors so which is fully
capable of doing
http pipelining don't pipeline too much
because you risk a lot
but you can also configure the number of
connection
for to each destination if you want to
do so so
it's actually pretty great that you can
configure all those things uh note that
if you're doing if you're using unity
for testing
you might want to disable or reduce
deeply reduce
the keep alive so you can actually
change the setting
and essentially configure the global
dispatcher for for the thing
you can also use the lower level apis so
you can conf
create a pool for a target destination
so it creates a pool
with a target pipelining and connection
numbers um
and then you can just call request as it
was before you can create a client
a client map one single socket again you
can do all those things
uh you know it's one at a time we also
have these
interesting methods called uh
stream request dispatch we have pipeline
we have a lot of things we have a lot of
options in term of
uh integration that you can do
oh by the way i was almost uh
forgetting we also have support for max
this is one of the greatest thing that i
really wanted to get in on the gv4
this is not in v3 when the gv4 is coming
out these days
when you watch this it might be already
get out but it's still not at this time
so uh it's still in the release
candidate phase so you can install it
with mpmi
v4 v4.0.0
for example with the mark
you can actually you know configure a
global agent a global dispatcher
for that will mark the
response and you can also enable a
pass-through mode so you can only mock
certain things
this is really important because in
[Music]
in order to support mocks for example in
the knock
or in the knot core hdp there to rely a
lot on monkey patching internals
not core internals however we've done
monkey patch
with this is no monkey patching
happening at all
you can just create one and it will just
work
so it's pretty pretty great because you
can also use it for testing
your libraries so i really love it
um how does this compare is this fast
enough
well let me show you so if we are
considering just
a a a a a very
uh a very simple system uh with
this simple system as before with the
keep alive
if we don't enable pipelining there's
not much effort here
but if we enable pipelining we can
dramatically and drastically include
increase the number of requests per
second that node core can send
why well because we are minimizing the
number of
uh round trips to the
uh underlining um
to the kernel and the operating system
anyway
and we are using our socket the best the
most essentially
so for me this is pretty pretty great uh
i also done some benchmarks on http 2
using this library called fastified gtp
proxy it's a simple http
proxy system that is built on top of
node.js and fastify
that can do htv one to htv one but also
http 2 to http 2 but also http
jtpd 1.1 and vice versa so it also uses
unity by default
for http 1.1 4gb 1.1 which is great
so you see it's fast actually uh
and you know i'm pretty pretty happy
about this
so hey uh it's actually pretty good now
i know that this can be improved quite a
lot potentially because this is using
one single connection and we
might be eating some sort of hcp2 limit
so yeah yeah this can be improved even
but
i'm pretty happy about lunch
so um i am almost wrapping up i just
want to say that
uh i want to recommend to you always use
if you ever
haven't watched this talk you want to
just get the most out of it
always set an http agent uh check out
owndichv4
and if you if you have the problem of
doing a lot of
microservice system and http holds the
unique one that
can actually drastically reduce the
overhead for yourself with the system
um so hey pretty great we have a new
docs website so
https and
undic.js.org yes it's part of node okay
only is a part of node.js project now
so it's it's pretty great from uh
from my point of view
we need help there is uh we need people
to use undigi and file bugs so that we
can fix them
please do that we can also send prs
there's a lot of activity is one of the
most active projects in the node.js
organization
so hey pretty neat
right um i also want to
uh to show
uh
nice oh here we go
like um
i also would like to show you a little
bit of uh
uh of a demo of
uh of funding so here we go
so let's see that we have a server so
this is a server
that does a few things and
you know you can see it uh it's pretty
it's pretty new syntax so using the new
esm
we can actually iterate over the
incoming events in camera requests
we await for the number of uh to the
server be listening and then we start
posting our request
pretty nice right i am i pretty i
i like this syntax so um then i can
actually do
uh the node server right so
if i do that i then i can say for
example i can curl it
and here you go yeah yeah it actually
you know
works cool um
now how can we use you one digi to call
to queries this server
well we can actually open up this other
code
which use the global request method from
mundichi
we extract a bunch of things and then we
console.log it essentially
so let's see if it works cool whoa it
seems
it's working because we are actually
replying that
it's uh it's saying that we
we have a date uh it's a 200
and it it tells us that the server want
to keep this connection alive for five
seconds
and it has a content length of 11
characters
those 11 characters are a low word
hooray and if you're looking on the
server you see we have
access slash foo so um it's
pretty great from from what i can see
uh going back to to our slide
um we can
i just wanted to to finish up by uh
pointing out to the fantastic high
performance browser networking book by
ilia grigorik
you can also read it online for free at
hpbn.com
check it out i talked a lot about
fastify so fastify.io here you go
and then we have undici and there is a
guide on the event loop and finally not
clinic if you want to optimize your
servers
we are about to wrap up so i will just
thank you very much
for having me uh you can reach me on
twitter at motocolina and also send me
an email
asking for anything essentially life the
universe and everything everything
at mateo.colina at nearform.com